rimmed around and controlled by the rookie kie
four assist to lead all NHL rookies to the ex
King dery gained the Kings line got rubbed out
by gabov puck still deep in the king Zone mcbaine
threw it behind the net where it's centered and
they score mcbaine on the rebound of a boy shot
a goal 259 in one- nothing coyotes sliding in
behind that Gap is right there Matt Roy was
facing the shooter it's a great example we saw it
recently where the rebound is very difficult to
anticipate so here's the shot look at Matt he's
trying to block it now where's the rebound going
I'm sure Phoenix is going to say maybe I could
have done a better job right there holding on
Matt Dumba side of the net a chance by Dumba
hit the outside of the post now in front and
a chance for Boyd to stop by cley so Kee to the
circle ccle holding feeds it up top Dy pressured
got it to fiala fiala shoots blocked rebound
chance copar save DY for K to Dy a shot block
loose Puck fala shoots it over the net good look
on a play the coyotes thought they had control
of fala again CL SI it comes and they score the
captain onj Kopitar and the game is tied at one
practicing one timers way more than he ever has
before now this one here he has to go down to his
knee and we were talking if copi ever becomes
dangerous with a one timer then that just adds
another weapon to the Arsenal and you can see how
he just gets along F will pick up assist number
eight on the season Copart gets it with torque on
his stick doesn't waste any motion golender has
to spread and open up that's a good thing for the
Kings the that r maybe you watched oetkin earlier
tonight oetkin had 10 shots through two periods
here's lazad moving in shot score Trevor Lewis as
lazard's backhander was blocked but Lewis Banks
home the lose pck starts way behind the net look
at the regroup speed all the way across the ice
that's a theme we've seen so far then the entry
because of that speed now it's kind of a broken
Play Because grundstrom Drive to the net but
without n1's drive there look at two Defenders
go to grundstrom Loose Change for Trevor Lewis
driving down low over skates the puck tied up by
Dumba Deno is in Deno will leave it right Circle
Moore swings it to the net looking to get it
to Anderson and now J centers score Trevor
Moore 3-1 la to recover a loose puck now
what that yeah what that does Jim it it
just confuses the defense they've got one more
body that they have to track in the defensive
end there he is right there he's going down
and now okay now it changes coverages look at
Den know when he gets here he has so much time
Anderson will get the secondary assist you just
love to see that wow what a pass what a pass
yeah they were moving up and down the ice in
units of five and Winer play connected like that
the kings are a real solid Hockey Club Trevor
Hansen Jordan Samuels Thomas Are the referees
tonight this is their first time back to a
Kings game since CO as well and they're having
a blast you guys having fun yeah you heard it
guys CR a chance save score on the rebound bstat
and the coyotes have made it a one goal game Nick
buad and then how quickly the coyotes are able
to to reattach back on the play it seems like
it's a broken play and it is but here's here's
what Todd has been talking about it's coverages
after the drop of the puck and Lane for Kow
and Lane for buad bad's going to win that
battle griov broken up but again Roy with it for
laella and Roy will get it down Kings have not
been as direct here in Period number two we
saw those attacks they had the Kings did in
Period number one turnover dowy feeds the middle
shot score BL was [Music] [Applause] [Music]
on bottom line Factor icing waved off grundstrom
makes it happen and then you're going to see
what's happening here watch the coyotes right
there that's just a weak pass dermit goes in
behind and all of a sudden look at look at grun
again even though he's not involved in the goal
so to speak up top for Jersey they want schaltz
there he isers to schaltz to Keller Keller top of
the right Circle base of the circle to the net
Keller across kulie fires it to the right and
a goal on a one-time great Puck movement down
low and Clayton Keller has made it a one-goal
game this is actually one of those where you see
schaltz I mention they want him they get him down
low he's right there he doesn't could make the
expected pass and that that is just finding the
open man changing the port of attack darl you
talked about that pregame where they just keep
changing where they've got to make sure they
keep their foot on the gas play in the other
Zone and be stingy defensively yeah holding
leads it was one of the themes when we talked
to players before the season started they want to
improve this year they have another opportunity
here to make sure no Second Chance Kings win the
draw Spence the garkov to the Circle a shot and
a loose pun score Kevin fiala the original shot
snuck behind the goal tender and it was pounced
on by fiala his first of the year Well Kevin told
us he's was going to shoot more right he'll take
that one off of Face Off so now the Kings get one
back you see how you had to work to get it there
it is now they M's going to say you know what
I saw it all the way there's no screen there's
no change in Direction he's got to hold on he
thinks he has it fala has it but at least the
Kings get one back on a face off great job there
by fiala high and wide on the short side Jersy
up high again for Keller right side up high in
the middle maltz to Keller a shot save is made
rebound loose pton tried to make a play couldn't
Lewis couldn't clear Jersy shoots tip and and a
score Hayton right as the penalty was expiring
54 LA right there and that's where it's picked
off and we we saw that from Shawn Jersey last
year right didn't we he he does a great job on
those north south passes where he just gets it now
there's a challenger here on offside wow challenge
by the Kings offside after review of the coach's
challenge the play was determined to be offside no
goal so Todd's uh percentage is increasing
50% now on the challenges Foot Race by field
pressuring dery who hands it off to Keller
Keller through Center a feet on right wing
broken up by the Kings picked up kempe shot
at the empty net moves in and scores [Music]
I thought his play tonight on those grinding
gritty non-scoring situations was excellent
and the kings are going to wrap it up here
at crypto.com Arena Boyd moving in can't get
around a Defender with the puck and the Kings
have their first home WI of the young season